john major you're the best cop in the  united 84  suitability  hello  jesus no but we both came back from the  dead  they rebuilt me with computers so he is  a robot  no yeah does that mean that you can't  die damn right it does  no  you're gonna be okay he's a work in  progress oh  it's like we're back and see these clams  after all no  in this country we drive on the left  what  [Applause]  are you talking to sleep i don't know  stop me all right  are you sure you didn't have any bits  left over when you finish rewiring  i've got unfinished business out there  it's judgment day  oh my shooting  you've come back a really crap compact  major what are you doing you're  forgetting that narcotics don't affect  me anymore  are you sure i'm pretty sure yeah  we got crimes to solve  you